hi there everyone this is Keith Moore
he's the head librarian at the Royal
Society some of you may recognize him
already
a lot of you won't we're going to show
you something and then I'll tell you
something else about Keith that's really
interesting this is a letter from the
archives at the Royal Society and it's
written by one very famous mathematician
- another one it's written by John
Herschel - Charles Babbage this is no
formal boring stuffy letter in fact
Keith tell us a little bit about what
this is well this is from quite an early
period and in the life of Herschel and
Babbage says is 1817 are quite young men
they're talking about George peacock one
of them mathematician friends they're
talking about an election certificate
for something doesn't quite say what but
what Herschel says is that peacock is a
noodle for neglecting it so and if you
have done the same as Babbage you are a
doodle I digest it as you may a doodle
do these are senior scientists Brady
they call each other noodles and oh yes
they are
mathematician they're quite young anyway
the thing I want to show all of you the
numberphile viewers is what's on the
next page of this letter because it's
quite interesting to look at and it
might be a bit of a puzzle let's have a
look what's next here I'm going to turn
the page now the letter continues here
on the left and you can see it's signed
off with the signature of Herschel
himself but what's really interesting is
here on this facing page besides a
little bit of the original wax there
from sealing the letter he's written
something here Keith what is he written
I'm not doing that to sort of bring you
into the video I'm doing it because I
can't read the handwriting
what's he written here so what he said
is a PS almost is interpret this
hieroglyphic it contains a great
discovery
so apparently hidden within this picture
that Herschel the famous Herschel has
drawn and sent to the equally famous
Babbage is some kind of discovery is
there a mystery a puzzle what's going on
it is so you what you have here is this
central figure which Herschel says is
Dionysus the god of
function's alias a genius of abstract
numerical magnitude and you can see that
he's surrounded not just by some random
figures here but some of the drawing
itself is made up of numbers so you can
probably see warms and zeroes here and
there's a little bit on the end so what
Herschel is saying is getting in here
there's something very important I kind
of doubt it but maybe the viewers can
tell us I don't know neither of us a
mathematician that's right we need help
okay I will put an image of this
elsewhere on the Internet you can check
out the video description there'll be
more information but if you find things
like this interesting if you love these
old documents old scientific objects
things like that Keith and I get
together every week on another youtube
channel called objectivity there'll be a
link to that on the screen in the
description sometimes stuff like this
sometimes it's machines sometimes it's
telescopes we did one of an Isaac
Newton's telescope every week a really
cool new object we've done nearly 30 of
them already check it out if it's
something you haven't seen already and
if you do watch it well thanks and
thanks for this Keith I'm going to get
to work her figuring this out thank you
here we go there we go look so there's
the earth turning as I turn the handle
day to night seriously I love this thing
I think I think if the Royal Society was
on fire which I hope never happens this
would be one of the things I would grab